who's going to speak about
it but you might have thought so they're
completely unrelated but let's
all right thanks Scott
um
so this is going to be uh sort of a
survey talk uh talking about works of
Harlow Hayden uh Scott Aronson and zika
prakarski but I'll try to talk about it
kind of from A New Perspective it's
based on some conversations I had with
Sam gone and Alex Lombardi last fall
also this is hopefully not going to be a
very technical talk I think I only have
like half an hour of content planned
um and so hopefully you'll be out of
here quickly
um so yeah I just want to start out with
a question that I'm sure we've all asked
ourselves at some point
um what does black hole radiation
decoding have to do with Quantum
cryptography
and luckily for us uh this is actually
answered in a paper of zika prakerski
not too long ago
um black hole radiation decoding is
quantum cryptography
uh yeah so let's let's look at this
title for a second
um you know I'd be wondering uh
what does this mean
um and depending on your background uh
like what is quantum cryptography right
and uh one part I haven't highlighted
yet uh
what does it mean for these two
obviously not the same things to be the
same thing
um so one goal of this talk at least
will be to at least understand the title
of zika's paper like what is what does
he mean
so a little more concretely my plan for
today is I'm just going to start with a
bit of background on black holes so just
a Bare Bones uh recap of what we need to
know to understand this computational
problem
I'll talk about this radiation decoding
problem defined by Harlow and Hayden
but I'm going to write down a slightly
different problem I like to call the
radiation distinguishing problem
and from that I'm going to draw a
connection to Quantum commitments and
three and four is going to be sort of a
an alternative view of zika's results
okay
um so let's start with this
um actually uh before I do that um it's
going to be like abundantly clear in
just a second that I don't know anything
about physics at all uh so here's a
warning slide for that and everything
I'm going to say about black hole
physics I learned from reading chapter
six of Scott aaronson's Barbados lecture
notes they're really good
um and they're like a strict superset of
everything I know about black hole
physics
I already see a mistake
mistake
what's the mistake the mistake is that
you may very well be copying my mistakes
all right well let's get to it so
according to Scott this is what a black
hole looks like
um
it's like a big purple circle uh
uh that's the Event Horizon and at the
middle uh Singularity is like a fancy
word for center of the black hole
um
and
uh according to Scott black holes emits
qubits of Hawking radiation
so that's one thing we should know
um and actually every outgoing qubit of
Hawking radiation is actually maximally
entangled with some in-falling qubit so
it has this partner Photon or maximally
entangled and its partner is Falling
Towards a singularity
okay and uh these black holes uh uh emit
radiation they're losing energy and
therefore losing mass and if you wait
long enough enough of it radiates
eventually the black hole evaporates
completely
and the one other thing we have to know
about this radiation is that the emitted
radiation comes out in a really
scrambled form
so that means uh at least for the
purposes of this talk or Simplicity
we're going to think about the post
evaporation state so if you let the
black hole evaporate completely and then
you gather up all of the qubits of
Hawking radiation it's ever emitted over
its lifetime we're going to think of
that as basically a random pure state
and one consequence of taking this
perspective is black hole it's really
scrambling information
is that after about one half the black
hole has evaporated a little more than
one half
uh that point the the qubits of
radiation that are coming out start to
be like really correlated with the
radiation that's come up before that
point
okay in fact the we'll say that the
outgoing qubits are maximally entangled
with the previously emitted radiation
so this is a funny picture
uh doesn't this violate monogamy of
entanglement
all right we have this one qubit of
radiation coming out and I claimed that
it's maximally entangled with its in
falling qubit but also maximally
entangled with all the previous
radiation yeah
when it's maximally entangled with an
in-fallen qubit that's behind the Event
Horizon
I mean I mean globally it would be a
pure state if you include the influence
yeah okay
um
uh so the physics answer to this is
something called a black hole
complementarity by saskand and uh and
this uh says that well um this this
outgoing qubit is actually entangled
with two different systems one outside
the black hole and one inside the black
hole then uh actually they're not two
different systems they're actually two
different perspectives of the same
system
uh so that's fine uh but turns out
there's still a problem even if you
accept this or still seems to be a
problem and uh this is a paper on
something called the firewall Paradox by
almiri moralsinski and salty they gave a
thought experiment in which it seems
like a single Observer can actually
detect uh this monogamy violation
so if we really want to like understand
Blackwell's complementarity we have to
kind of sort out what's going on with
this
both of them
with both of these residents
yeah so uh the entanglement with the in
following qubits is I guess a prediction
of quantum field Theory uh uh I don't
really know more to say about that but
there's apparently uh maximally
entangled like we would expect to see a
bunch of uh epr pairs that's like
straddle The Event Horizon and uh the
the guy on the inside because it's
inside the Event Horizon is kind of
stuck there it's going to fall towards
the singularity and the guy on the
outside sometimes like just shoots out
and so like this prediction that like
you have a bunch of epr pairs around the
Event Horizon is kind of uh I think what
Quantum field Theory size you have and
like vacuum space
um and for the so that's that's uh
that's that guy
is this guy and this one is just a
prediction or a consequence of modeling
like the global State as a random pure
stage so if you think of the global
state of like all n qubits of Hawking
radiation that will ever be emitted as
like a parandom state
my claim is that if I trace out a small
number of qubits like actually up to
about half of them the resulting state
is actually still kind of like a random
pure State and those have lots of
entanglements
so this one is sort of a Quantum
information prediction uh and and this
is like a Quantum field Theory
prediction
does that answer the
um
so uh what is the app's experiment
well the idea is that Alice is going to
set up a black hole
um so she's going to uh actually set it
up in a state that she knows even
um
and what she's going to do is sit
outside the black hole and basically uh
set up a bunch of like Photo detectors
all around the Black Hole uh to collect
all of the Hawking radiation that it
ever emits
and she's going to do this for a really
really really long time she's going to
do this until two-thirds of the black
hole has evaporated
and then at this point
um she's going to use a quantum computer
to sort of check like detect this
entanglement that she expects to see
that that is expected to be there
between the next outgoing qubit of
radiation and all the radiation she's
seen so far right like as I just argued
right we expect this qubit should be
maximally entangled with this this a
bunch of qubits and all Alice is going
to do is process these qubits through
her quantum computer
and it's going to do something to these
qubits and sort of arrange them so that
the leftmost qubit here this blue guy is
maximally entangled with the next qubit
coming out and we guarantee like we're
guaranteed that this like doing this is
possible right we we know that these are
these are actually maximally entangled
so it is possible to do something to
this side that'll turn this into an epr
pair zero zero plus one one with this
next outgoing qubit
okay
so he's going to just check that these
guys are maximally entangled
uh and then after doing that check
she will just jump into the black hole
so she carries her qubit in with her and
then searches for the partner qubit and
uh checks that those are actually
maximally entangled and she's like whoa
like that shouldn't happen
so I think in the original amps paper uh
what they propose is that well you know
if you really want to keep leaving in
like our modern understanding of physics
which we expect to apply around the
Event Horizon of a black hole then
there's got to be something breaking
that entanglement between the outgoing
qubit and the in following qubit
um and and breaking this entanglement
will release energy so they predict that
uh that there's got to be some kind of
firewall right outside of the The Event
Horizon like breaking all these epr
pairs
and I think that a lot of people found
this sort of unsettling that this notion
of like the the firewall would appear
right outside the Event Horizon is kind
of uh doesn't really line up with what
we expected to happen
um at the Event Horizon
so uh fast forward a couple years uh
Harlow and Hayden proposed a very
different resolution to the amps Paradox
uh not based on firewalls but instead
based on computational complexity
um and I think this is very cool and
surprising
um
so what they said is well uh you know
something is fishy with the second step
um the second step of this app
experiment
um particular they argued is that under
certain cryptographic assumptions uh the
Second Step where Alice is running her
quantum computer to process all this
radiation and and come up with a single
qubit here such that these two are an
epr pair that this is actually a
computationally hard task
that under uh certain cryptographic
assumptions this step can require
exponential time and exponential here is
like exponential in some black hole
parameter like like its mass for
instance and so what that means or what
Harlow Hayden showed is that
um by the time that she's actually done
decoding uh we'll we'll expect that the
black hole has like long evaporated and
there's nothing for her to jump into to
observe this violation
okay so let me uh State this radiation
decoding problem a little bit more
carefully
um so India is you're going to let C be
some publicly known uh polynomial size
Quantum circuit
and we'll Define the state PSI to be the
result of running C on the all zero
stage
and we're going to think of PSI as
corresponding to the final state of all
of the emitted radiation
so uh this is the picture and we're
going to further divide these registers
into three kinds of registers the first
we'll call R for radiation uh actually
they're all radiation so
um we'll call this R but uh this is for
the radiation that's emitted so far so
this is uh the the 2N over three qubits
that that Alice has collected like all
waiting for this black hole to evaporate
uh the next wire the single qubit is B
and this is just the the next qubit
shooting out of the black hole and H is
kind of everything else that'll that'll
come out later but we're gonna sort of
ignore h
and my claim is that in the amp
experiment uh Alice is essentially doing
the following task she's she's given the
r register of the state
um she's not given the B and H registers
and she has to run some computation
given just this part of the state that's
going to Output a single qubit a
such that A and B is the epr state 0 0
plus 1 1.
and the promise is that uh this task is
statistically possible that um R and B
like this are register and the single
qubit B are actually maximum entangled
so we know that this can be done uh the
task is just to do it
pause for a few seconds and just let
this sink in
yeah any questions on this uh
yeah we said the state was a high random
stage yeah
uh yeah I guess what I'll say about that
is that
um and you're totally right so the
question was I was saying that the
output is a horror random State uh and
then I'm modeling this as a uh
polynomial size circuit so a few things
um first off I guess in the direction of
like showing this task is hard
um we don't have to worry about that
because if we show that it's hard for
like a polynomial size circuit then I
mean we should maybe be like extra
convinced that it's going to be hard for
like a true a harmonic mistakes uh I
guess the other thing is that
um and we also expect that like the the
black hole unit is very inefficient
um efficient in the sense of like
polynomial in some like enormous
parameter uh so actually the thing about
it being a hot random state is also like
a bit of a lie too
it's just like it's supposed to be very
scrambled but like maybe about as
scrambles you can get
right no I mean I mean I mean nowhere in
the firewall argument do you need
anything to be R random right yeah I
mean there's a certain point where you
appeal to the scrambleness of the state
yeah what's going to happen at the page
time right yeah um that's really going
to be true for the output of like a
poly-sized random circuit as well
um
um we just need anything that will like
okay the only thing we really need is
that D and R are statistically entangled
um like that's that's what that's the
thing we uh concluded from uh the heart
Randomness but you know it that's true
for other states too
is enough
sorry
yeah R is like a scrambled version of
the AQ bits right so it's like you know
morally R is Like A and B but it's like
scramble then your your task is to like
understand how they're scrambled
when they say a b is API like the resist
state
oh like like a is a single cubes and uh
I guess what you can do is when the the
adversary outputs is qubit a
um here like the referee the person
running the experiment can just do a
productive measurement on the two qubit
State a b and check if it's a epr state
so I have more basic question like in
the previous pictures you show that
these these two qubits that are actually
entangled they appear on the horizon and
one Falls in and the other one escapes
yeah so like why would the black hole
evaporate it should be getting bigger
because there's always green kills
why would the Blackpool evaporate why
are in cubits are falling
I mean if enough is falling in then the
black hole will never evaporate but you
know if you just imagine that stuff
Falls in at one time and then it's left
in a vacuum for all you know eternity
that eventually is a little bit
but I think the question was like even
if I don't assume that like nobody's
like throwing anything into the black
hole Yeah because he's asking uh if this
just this thing falling in right
is that the question yeah like I mean
every time a cubit escapes you're saying
also keep it falls in
there's isn't it yeah it's actually I
mean I was I was confused about the same
thing apparently in Quantum field Theory
when there are these virtual pairs it's
negative energy that goes into the black
hole and it's positive energy that comes
out of it although I guess if you were
inside the black hole and you saw that
in Falling Cubit it wouldn't look to you
like negative energy it would look like
positive energy we really think of this
as a qubit right
Patrick do you um
pretty good
yeah but the question is you know how
how does uh like a negative energy a
virtual particle go in from the external
perspective and yet from the internal
perspective there's a positive energy
in following particles
are these are these just two different
things
like dusting formation increase while
the energy drops
not defined in VR as the cheap answer
so these server inside doesn't usually
see the an involving
uh qubit because the if you're an
in-falling observer right uh you know
you cross the Horizon and you see vacuum
right it's because someone outside is
accelerating relative to the black hole
right and so inside you don't really see
anything
still I mean
explanation of energy you still have
more qubits if I just view this in
qubits then why do I count on the energy
and not just the number of students oh
well that's that's part of the Paradox
actually right
no no no that's the question right this
picture in which there are maximally
entangled pairs get you know produced
one after the other from that
perspective it looks like the entropy of
the black hole should just be keep going
up and up and up and up and up oh right
so right I'll also keep in mind that
these info and Cupids they're all going
to hit the singularity
you know
who knows what happens to them there
oh yeah
which one yes just when you explain
so what's the problem by the time the
palace is done recording the black holes
so especially I'm not going to jump into
like they experiment like the third step
is you need to drop in for this like
later radiation that you can potentially
Within
um
yeah I guess but the later rate like you
won't find a contradiction there anymore
you won't find like another maximilating
thing that's fair like once you wait for
all the later radiation to come out
you're just staring at some some like
random random looking into your stage
random looking States and if I'm staring
at that I'm not gonna find a a monogamy
violation
I really have to like go in while the
black hole is still there
[Music]
we have any questions on this uh
questions are great this is super
confusing so
yeah I'm a bit like you I don't have any
background in physics but this Paradox
feels a little bit relativistic in the
sense that what you've shown me is not
saying that the Paradox does not exist
but a an observer cannot observe
violation
okay
I can like the
the general philosophy behind these
things right is that
at least that yeah things are better
understood now 10 years later but at the
time people were
proposing these thought experiments and
if you if there's there seems to be some
Paradox or contradiction yeah
thought experiment
um
that's you know that's potentially a
problem for your understanding of
quantum gravity but if you find that
there's an in principle reason in the
theory that you can't verify that there
was a paradox then that might be a hint
that uh
that the underlying Theory
um
does not have a problem
right and so
what this was about was saying okay well
it seems that there's this firewall
Paradox right it seems that there's this
violation of quantum mechanics a
violation of monogamy of entanglement
but if it's impossible in principle to
ever verify that it exists
um then maybe that's yeah and we can
uh then maybe that's a sign that there
really isn't a paradox once we actually
have the proper theory of quantum
gravity uh it just explains yeah it
shows that there is nothing to worry
about
um so that was that's sort of the
philosophy thinking of these uh these
thought experiments and asking because
it's the same idea as you know
Heisenberg way back when you know
thinking about the uncertainty principle
he didn't start with the mathematics he
said she said okay well I have this
particle I want to figure out where it
is how do I figure out where it is I
send in some other particle it's going
to bounce off of it uh and if I do that
yeah if I want to really figure out the
high accuracy where it is I end up
needing a high energy particle that
imparts a lot of momentum and so it was
thinking through those kinds of thought
experiments that led to the uncertainty
principle and then taught us that
position momentum are not independent
and so it's the same kind of philosophy
here trying to ask you know what are the
underlying restrictions on what you can
actually know so you can understand what
the actual degrees of freedom and
structure of the theory are
yeah so so as long as uh you know before
that before this Fireball Paradox
um you know there was this notion that
both
the same Observer cannot cannot see see
a contradiction and so maybe you can
perform
reality into two and say well these two
are two versions of the same reality but
now if you're saying look
um
it's computationally hard impossible to
you know it's it takes exponential time
to Jacqueline notice a contradiction
how do you
you know what how would you imagine the
underlying reality looks you can't fold
it but what can you do with it but
um
could I put a pin in that question
it's a good question
so yeah I'll go the next slide
I'll keep the radiation decoding problem
up at the top
um
and uh but Harlow Hayden showed that
um if bqp is not contained in the
complexity class called statistical zero
knowledge so problems that admit
statistical zero knowledge proofs
yeah
um should have had a complexity Theory
disclaimer too yeah
then there exists some circuit C such
that uh radiation decoding is hard
um away I should say like right now it's
like what is what is hard
um I think uh zvika has sort of pushed
for this uh more careful definition of
like the probability threshold
um or hard should really mean that no
adversary no Quantum polynomial time
adversary and win with probability uh
noticeably better than a quarter because
one quarter is sort of your trivial win
probability if the game is implemented
by like the adversary outputs is qubit a
and then the Challenger just checks
whether it's the epr state okay so
that's a one state and four-dimensional
space so uh if you're not doing anything
because if you measure in the Bell basis
like the max we mix that you'll get the
right answer you want yeah
yeah exactly if you just if you just
output junk you're going to win with one
quarter probability so it should be hard
to do better than that
um and uh well if you're making uh
assumptions to uh and and you care about
their conclusions well you typically
want to make the weakest assumptions
possible and uh later works did
successfully uh weaken the assumptions
you needed to conclude uh hardness of
this radiation decoding problem
um so uh Scott a few years later showed
how to argue radiation decoding hardness
under the assumption that there exists
Quantum secure one-way functions
possibly injective one-way functions I'm
not really sure which one you needed
yeah I found some slides that also did
this and I wasn't sure
um right I think that maybe injective is
incomparable to this I'm not sure
um I think like one-way functions would
be weaker but injective I think is
technically uncomfortable I think
morally it's a much weaker assumption
right okay
um
and uh very recently uh zvika prakerski
got this all the way down to the
existence of quantum bit commitments
um which turned out to be a much much
weaker or potentially much much weaker
assumption than the existence of quantum
secure one-way functions and I'll just
say like the the difference here is that
this is a a classical cryptographic
primitive this is like a classical
function that's hard to invert hard to
invert by a Quantum machine
um but a Quantum bit commitment refers
to a Quantum protocol uh one where like
you use quantum communication to commit
to a bit and uh in the recent progress
in Quantum cryptography uh complexity as
sort of pointed out that this is a
potentially much weaker assumption that
like there is a world like for instance
a Oracle result saying that you might
have a world where one-way functions
don't exist but still a Quantum bit
commitments are possible
so it's a fairly a very very weak
cryptographic assumption and turns out
um you're probably not going to be able
to weaken it any further because zika
bakerski also approved the reverse
Direction so we showed that hardness of
radiation decoding actually implies
existence of quantum events so from an
existential standpoint these two
problems are totally equivalent
and let me just emphasize like why
cryptographers like really should care
about this
um and Quantum big commitments are not
just this like one-off uh cryptographic
primitive they're really like this like
Central like Workhorse of quantum
cryptography uh it turns out that
Quantum commitments imply or actually
are equivalent to a bunch of other
really essential Primitives like on
oblivious transfer multi-party
computation uh Quantum zero knowledge
protocols for say NP or even qma
um and savika's words uh not mine Um
this can be viewed as providing a
physical justification for the existence
of secure cryptography so for instance
if you like really really believe that
Alice should not be able to trigger a
firewall around the Event Horizon
um and you like make a bunch of other
assumptions like you really believe that
uh that like physics should hold true uh
the qft and gr are true around the Event
Horizon uh then then in some sense this
is saying that like we can we can use
that as evidence that there are uh
cryptographically useful uh
computational problems that are actually
hard
um so very like very different from the
way we typically
um like uh justify uh assumptions and
cryptography right usually it's that oh
mathematicians have tried really hard
for 50 years and mathematicians are
really smart so like if they haven't
solved it then maybe it's just hard
um this is saying like maybe like
there's actually like evidence from
physics that that some problems are just
computationally intractable
um
this is what do you mean
we know that unconditionally secure
yeah so this is this is an argument that
that uh computational leads to care uh
Quantum victim that's kind of like exist
yeah like instead of proving like a
circuit lower bound and saying like
physics is like physics is telling us
that actually it's secure
um or or maybe the truth is just that we
can create the firewall it just takes
some yeah yeah some non-trivial
engineering that hasn't been done yet
yeah so
yeah
um win-win you wanna
um
I mean it's gonna like years ago Seth
Lloyd you know you know his argument for
the second uh uh for uh uh like P naught
equal to NP is that if P equals NP then
probably you could exploit it to create
a Maxwell demon
yeah
and then we leave it so I think there
are many steps that remain to be filled
in in this argument but yeah
but yeah I think that's a similar flavor
yeah yeah so there's still this like
science wins either way flavor
flavor
um so uh
okay so today
um for the rest of this talk I'll try to
explain like how this how this crypto
connection Works
um I'm going to do it a little
differently from How uh
um
and I'm going to go through this uh and
radiation distinguishing problem so
instead of like directly looking at this
um the original radiation decoding
problem that I just defined I'm going to
define a new uh I'll call it radiation
distinguishing question
uh so just to keep the old problem in
mind this is the decoding problem the
one where you're given R and you're
asked to decode a single qubit a
um but really like the point of this
problem uh as far as far as we could
tell
um is that like R and B are guaranteed
to be maximally entangled but the the
problem with trying to capture the fact
that this entanglement should not be
efficiently detectable
okay
uh and the reasoning is really that if
this is the point of the problem then
you can write down a different problem
that also or that like very directly
captures
um this this point only this radiation
distinguishing question so what I'll do
is it's now a distinguishing game so the
adversary just needs to guess uh like
which uh which Quantum state it received
okay so we'll have a challenger it's
going to flip a flip a coin and either
it's going to give the adversary the
actual R and B registers the ones that
are actually entangled
or it's going to replace the B register
this B qubit with some unrelated
maximally mixed qubit B Prime
so B Prime is just not entangled with r
and the adversary's job is to
distinguish
um which one I got
right so it wins if it guesses correctly
which world it's in and its goal is to
guess correctly with probability better
than one half
so how do these problems relate uh well
distinguishing is definitely easier than
decoding in the sense that if you can
solve this decoding problem with
Advantage 1 4 plus some Epsilon then you
can immediately solve the distinguishing
problem with that same advantage
so the idea is just that well if you're
in this world where you got the
unentangled states then if you run the
decoder on the r part then no matter
what it does no matter how fancy your
decoder is the chance that it outputs a
such that A and B prime or the epr state
is exactly what is at most one fourth
um and on the other hand if you're if
you run the decoder on R here then you
have a 1 4 plus Epsilon chance so if you
just guess which world you're in based
on whether or not your decoder succeeds
but you can check yourself
uh and you gotta distinguisher
so that's fine
um where I'm going to assume that you're
given the full description of C because
yeah
SC will always think of as public like
the only hardness is going to come from
not having the whole the whole state
hmm
okay
um at the same time uh I claim that uh
whatever arguments you make for physics
saying that the coding is hard
um should it apply like equally well to
distinguishing being hard right mainly
that like if Alice can't trigger a
firewall
um well the point is that she shouldn't
be able to attack any entanglement
between B and R and the Ants experiment
um and we should expect that it really
like it doesn't matter to Alice if she's
efficient whether she gets the actual
qubit b or some unrelated maximally
mixed qubit fee
um
so what's the point of uh writing this
one down like what what do I gain by
changing the problem to this uh the
claim is that this is already a natural
crypto assumption once you look at it
the right way like uh at least in the
Harlow Hayden paper uh
and Scott's work and zika's work
um you have to work a little bit I mean
it's not too hard but you still have to
do something to engineer the crypto to
fit the the syntax of this radiation
decoding problem uh and our claim is
just that if you write down this
question uh there's no engineering
required this is actually this is like
already a useful and natural
cryptographic object so the rest of this
talk is just going to try to explain
like why that is and the concrete claim
is that radiation distinguishing is hard
if and only if uh Quantum commitments to
the epr state exist
so uh what I'll do for the rest of this
time is just explain what that means so
what are uh what are commitments to
Quantum States and then why do Quantum
convince the epr state uh why are those
the same things as radiation
distinguishing problems
okay
um so like quickly uh Quantum State
commitment uh it's only very recently
like formally defined but it's kind of
been folklore for a long time
um the idea is just that the sender is
thinking of some Quantum State and it
wants to uh commit to this so the
physical like analogy is that imagine
just like the sender places its state in
a box like locks it up and sends that
box to the to the receiver and that's
the commitment and later it wants to
open this commitment and so it sends
some piece of opening information and
the receiver takes all the stuff and
verifies the opening is valid opens up
the box and recovers the the value the
state that the sender committed to
um and we typically want some security
properties so you might ask for hiding
and binding so hiding would say that the
commitment should hide the underlying
message or state PSI from the receiver
receiver should have no idea what's
inside it until it receives the opening
and binding should say that after it
gets the um after the sender sends away
the commitment it can't change its mind
anymore it can't you know commit to one
state PSI uh commit and then later be
like well actually I wanted to change
that to some orthogonal state for
instance
foreign
so just two things you should know about
Quantum about committing to Quantum
States uh first is that this requires
computational assumptions so there's a
well-known impossibility result from the
90s saying that when you use quantum
communication to commit to classical
bits that already requires computational
assumptions
and Quantum State commitments are just a
generalization to Quantum States but you
know zero and one are quantum States so
to do a Quantum statement you still need
computational assumptions
uh and one more thing is that uh while
the like functionality is a bit more
advanced it's actually pretty easy to
show that these are just existentially
equivalent to Quantum bit commitments
namely if you can commit to a bit and
you want to commit to a state what you
can do is like one time pad the state so
apply random polys and then commit to a
description of those polys and send that
along with the one-time padded state
so there's a easy like way to go between
Quantum debt commitments and Quantum
statements
um it's just that this abstraction is a
little friendlier with uh what we're
about to do
so
um
the syntax here is that
um the way that you commit is that we
just have a single unitary com that
specifies how the whole scheme works
and what the senator will do to commit
is it just runs this unitary on the
state it's trying to commit to together
with a bunch of zeros and then it splits
up the resulting registers the the
resulting state it gets into equipment
parts and the opening part
and so you send the Clinton part to
commit and then you send the rest of the
state to decommit later
and to verify the receiver is just going
to undo that unitary and then check the
last Lambda qubits are zero
and it turns out that um any any uh
commitment to Quantum States like even
like an interactive protocol can always
be like generically compressed to have
this syntax so this is like a without a
generality a way to write any Quantum
statement
um so for binding and hiding like what
do they mean in this context I'll look
at statistical binding and computational
hiding so statistical binding just says
that the commitment completely
determines what I'm committing to so
when I send this C register the state
that information theoretically
determines uh the message that I
committed to the PSI so
um concretely like one way to think
about this is that there exists some uh
probably inefficient unitary that can
recover the state's eye from the C
register alone
okay
so if I just have C there is some
unitary I can apply that'll reproduce
this size state
and computational hiding says that no
efficient adversary can distinguish
whether it gets a commitment to a state
sigh of its own choosing
or a commitment to a totally junk state
okay so in the security experiment here
like the adversary gets to pick whatever
message it wants it can prepare the
state however it would like even like
entangled with something else it holds
on to
and then it sends that say to the
Challenger and the Challenger gives back
either a commitment to that stage or a
commitment to some random unrelated junk
and the adversary's job is to tell which
is which
and The crucial point is like really
this indistinguishability needs to hold
even if the adversary has a state
entangled with with Psy
so uh like a natural like setting to
consider is
um what happens when you commit to the
epr state so I have an epr pair and
registers a b and I commit to the a
register
um
well statistical binding says that b the
other half of the epr pair that was not
involved in the commitment must be
maximally entangled with C right this is
just because uh C uh this is because C
completely determines a right from C You
Could reconstruct a so C must seem
actually entangled with B
and computational hiding says that even
if the adversary holds on to this B it
can't tell whether it gets a commitment
to the actual a qubit the one that's
entangled with B
or it gets a commitment to some
unrelated maximally mixed state
and one fun fact is that I can think of
this equivalently this B C Prime State
it's distributed identically to B Prime
C so you can imagine a world where the
adversary gets
um like the B register is replaced by
some other maximally mixed state and it
gets back the correct commitment to a
and the point is that this is in both
cases this B is maximally mixed and
unentangled with C Prime which is a
commitment to a maximum X state
and so when I put all this together uh
this is what it means to break the
hiding of the epr commitment
is that you have these registers b c and
d you're promised that B and C are
maximally entangled and your task is
distinguish BC from B Prime C where B
Prime is an unentangled maximum X qubit
and just remember that this was the
radiation distinguishing problem
they're exactly the same thing
um that's I just relabeled C with r
so uh if you have Quantum commitments
then just like is an immediate corollary
you have hard radiation distinguishing
um I mean if you have fun equipments you
can commit to any state particularly you
can commit to the epr state and that
means that this problem is hard
if you have Quantum communities to some
states you can come into anything uh
that's the next slide
uh so this is for One Direction that if
you have Quantum events to all states
then you certainly have Quantum events
to the epr state
by definition
um
one last thing
uh I need to show that at least for the
other direction where I want to conclude
that hard radiation distinguishing
implies the existence of cryptography I
need to show that the ability to commit
to the epr state
means that I can commit to any state
also this is only showing that the
radiation problem is like hard on worse
from worst case C right but like for
black holes who care about the actual C
that comes in the black hole really good
question let me hold off on that so I'll
talk about that okay
um but that same issue applies to sort
of everything like uh uh maybe like even
the worst of the original like uh Harlow
Hayden paper
um that like there you're like really
engineering uh a particular like C
um by like planting this this hard SDK
problem there
um whereas there's like a lot more seas
that we might expect to give Quantum
thicker Quantum statements but I'll get
back to that
um
okay so yeah one last thing is just the
ability to connect to an epr State means
you can commit to any state so I have to
justify this and then that that'll be
the full loop of woods and I'll just say
this is like a Quantum only thing like
in classical crypto there's no ethereum
that's like once I can commit to zero I
can commit to anything uh you really
have to be able to commit to more than
one thing
um but there is this one particular
state where if you commit to the epr
state you can commit to anything
um and the idea is if you can commit to
the epr state and you want to commit to
a different state PSI what you do is you
teleport PSI into that c register so to
commit to psi I'm going to measure PSI
together with this uh be qubit and I'll
measure in the Bell basis I'll get two
classical bits x and z and I send the
the epr commitment C together with x and
z
and in some sense you just think of this
as like this is like a a scrambled
version of like the teleported state
right like if the the point is that c
statistically determines this a cubit
and this a cubit together with x and z i
mean that's the result of teleportation
on the other side right that I have a as
well as these poly errors and that's
going to determine the state's PSI
and for computational hiding we know
that uh C together with x and z is
indistinguishable computationally
indistinguishable from C prime or C
Prime is just a commitment to unrelated
junk
and this is just something that is
completely independent of PSI
report later like send random x and z
then teleport and then okay there will
be some phases left later
the new skills I think you just get a
maximum state that comes out oh I see
um
corrected right but that would be kind
of allowing the adversary to break
okay like the the receiver kind of knows
how it's going to affect things and if
the adversary is like actually today I
want you to open this in a differently
the receiver will know that something is
up
um if the receiver like follows the
prescribed procedure for like
reconstructing the original state the
adversary won't be able to change it
um
okay so uh that's all I really had to
say
um is the point of this talk is that
there is a really like tight
relationship between a certain problem
in black hole physics uh and a natural
question or natural like cryptographic
primitive
um and one last thing about uh anan's
question is um you know there is this
choice of like C uh the choice of this
like black hole unitary that I was kind
of uh vague about this whole time
um and uh
uh it turns out that that's also a place
where you have a nice connection between
what you study in the black hole setting
and what we'd like to look at in
cryptography
um so I think in the black hole setting
you typically model c as a random
polynomial size circuit
um and at the same time I think like
kind of in parallel cryptographers are
coming around to this view that when you
want to commit to anything uh with a
unitary uh it's it seems pretty secure
to plug in a random circuit for that
unitary
um but I think this is kind of the like
one of the central questions uh to
pursue uh uh in Quantum cryptography uh
namely like just giving more evidence
for the hardness of this problem
um so I mean people have been studying
random circuits for quite a while now uh
but the kinds of problems that people
look at like these linear cross-century
problems
um you know it's plausible to me that
even those problems like could end up
actually being kind of easy and this
question of like breaking these like
random circuit commitments might still
be hard
um so I think it's just a like fantastic
question to give them better
understanding better evidence for
hardness of these questions
um and this is probably the simplest
like way I can think of to write down
this question uh this is basically
equivalent to all the computational
problems I've seated so far uh
particularly like just given a
description of a random circuit question
is like how hard is it to distinguish
the output of the circuit on two
orthogonal states
um if you're only given part of the
circuit output so 2N over three of the
qubits so this is a setting in which the
two states the two mixed States you
would see are statistically
distinguishable
um and the question is like how how hard
is it to actually do this extinguishing
and so uh like one consequence of all
this is like not only does this have
like huge cryptographic implications to
understand this question but it's like
very tightly related to understanding
like the the complexity of these same
questions for for Black Hole radiation
okay thanks
questions
yeah
Scott has something like directly
addressing this I'll let you take it
this question came up a decade ago so I
could tell you John Preston's answer to
it if the black hole is really
microscopic then we never expected you
know a semi-classical descriptions to
work for it anyway so then there's no
problem
right it's only when black holes get a
macroscopic scale that we expected
Quantum field Theory to work at all
um other yeah does this use it is
it for example some of the geometries we
had about this morning I can imagine
seeing would be
it's actually
do you think there are interesting
results in those cases
I mean isn't it just the quantum
extended Church during thesis you know
just the belief that like whatever is
going on in a black hole if you were
outside of it then you ought to be able
to simulate it efficiently yeah but
that's false that's a very big deal fair
enough but the way family said it's just
that the Sea comes from physics so I
just wonder if that's a natural yeah
thanks
I mean I mean I mean I mean I guess the
idea is that you take whatever is the
true quantum theory of gravity that
governs the scrambling and the
information and then you simulate that
using some your your hamiltonian
simulation
you know and that's what gives rise to
your polynomial sizes
if I just said suck it's socket size
oh
um
if there are maybe some lower bounds or
some like upper bounds AP on on how
secure this can be for login yeah
at least like if it's like if it's like
a Clifford T circuit and there's like
only certain like tea Gates
that might even be the next talk depth
login with two Cubit Gates only and but
with no spatial vocabulary because like
now now all these things matter yeah
uh yeah
let's talk about this uh four questions
so like in order to relate to the state
commitment into the more straightforward
way I would have thought the right
question would be distinguishing like C
applied to always your estate and C
applies to all zero State except one of
the qubits in an arbitrary States side
oh yeah yeah
um yeah because if I thought zero to the
N minus one concatenate one was ugly on
the slide
um but it's just two like different
states that just starting with them
being orthogonal
they're fixed anyway you know what they
are
uh shouldn't matter as long as it's all
this is just me writing down like uh
uh the property of being a secure
Quantum bit by the way is that their
mistakes and it's all sort of the same
thing
so like easier to think about Quantum
State commitments when you're like
writing on abstractions to connect
things to the black hole radiation to
coding problem uh but when you're
thinking about like the easiest like
problem to write down like the
computational question it's just this
one
the is there any like candidate
argument for this because I've actually
been asking this question for like many
years but I haven't gotten any
satisfactory answers from anyone
on
uh I don't know I mean you can try to
give like Oracle evidence for this at
least uh like you could ask I don't know
like how how much you would believe like
auric law then it's like sheds light on
this question like maybe you can do a
lot of fancy stuff when you have an
explicit description of the circuit uh
at least in the Oracle setting like this
seems very hard too like I give you
Oracle access to a hard military that's
inverse
ask you like to distinguish these the
same two things
um seems very very hard uh so I can say
I mean if we replace a random Circuit by
a different Ensemble then again it's
going to be at least as hard as you know
breaking injective blood Money functions
or whatever
yeah
so I guess that together with some
hypothesis that random circuits are the
worst yeah right like they only seem
harder yeah but then of course it's hard
to formalize that intuition
um anyone else yeah how important is it
two-thirds
oh uh not super important uh it's just
some parameter that makes the problem
you want to be in a regime where it's
actually a computational question that
the two mixed states are actually
statistically far
um so like that regime is basically like
pretty much everywhere between one half
and one
of London this looks kind of like the
blue one confirmation problem from
the same thing
so that that case was like when the
Fidelity between the traced out States
is one so like they're yeah yeah and
that problem was already unitary piece
based so like which we think is really
huge right yeah good so the question is
about like how this relates to this uh
online transformation problem uh it's
actually this is a question where you
have like a pair of pure States uh like
bipartite pure States and like on
registers a b and your promise that like
they're reduced densities on a are the
same uh and the task is that like almond
serum says that applying just a
Unitarian the B side you can turn one
into the other questions like how hard
is this
um that's like the the swapping
distinguishing Duel of this question
like if I take the sum of these like if
these states are hard to distinguish
like there's some and they're different
so like like if you add them up like
versus track them uh those two states uh
like Define like an older question
um but with that problem like from from
Henry un's paper yeah like like is there
any assumption that the states came from
a small circuit
um yeah I don't know exactly what they
say about like the random circuit
setting but right because that I mean
that might explain why they go all the
way up to piece yeah I think in that one
it's uniform in peace piece for kids so
it's a lot bigger problems yeah yeah
uh
yeah Henry U.N and students
studies like the the uh a bunch of
problems with Quantum inputs and Quantum
outputs and like they're unifying uh uh
ER problem is this almond transformation
problem
um anyone else
so if the uh the circuit is actually not
kind of uh sufficiently like randomizing
to make things entangled
but only like things only look entangled
you still get cryptographic partners
from that all right so there's this
those has worked on like sudo
entanglement right but uh I think talks
about this it's all right so I couldn't
quite follow the question you're saying
you have like a statistical guarantee on
the like that you you know statistically
that you can extract the EPL path from
this uh
um from I'll see you right back to the
decoding setup yeah exactly or whatever
like like statistically you put this
thing with
uh but uh maybe let's see uh
so I guess like there is there so
there's a like a statistical
binding and computational hiking
is there like like a
computational binding uh various that's
like assumes maybe something to do with
the oh
uh sorry are you asking can you switch
the guarantees so you can switch the
guarantees which I mean like like is
there an interpretation of uh
of the computational oh like for the
black hole setting yeah oh uh not only
for the epr comments and you just have
like a flavor switch DPR commitment you
guarantees are a switch but for black
holes uh I don't know
um
yeah I guess I don't have a very well
formulated question but like there's
some you know you could say well maybe
the these uh
radiation is not actively entangled
digital just sort of looks actually
entangled yeah
I don't know uh uh maybe yeah I don't
see it I don't see like how to interpret
that just yet yeah maybe there's
something there
um yeah yeah
good sorry
um
anyone else so
um Fermi do I understand correctly that
like even if P were equal to P space for
example like we still would not know how
to break all Quantum bit commitment
schemes uh that's a really good question
I think that uh uh I mean Willow was
asking me about something like I think
Will has like some partial thoughts on
this
um uh I haven't thought too hard about
the setting where you explicitly have a
description of the circuit uh I think
the uh
yeah I have more thoughts on what
happens if you model this as a random
unitary in an oracle
um but when there's an explicit
description I would expect that there
would be some kind of like complexity
like uh collapse that would make us easy
I just don't know what it is okay the
the reason I asked like the the main and
there's in my lecture notes in 2016. the
main open problem I gave about the
complexity of the harle Hayden problem
you know uh uh uh the converse right
yeah I don't think you mentioned this
but like you know if if uh uh I assume
some computational superpower then could
I decode walking radiation yeah
form in two regimes right one is like
for this question like I'm supposed to
give you a random circuit's description
yeah and the questions also well formed
in like an oracle model too where C is
like a hard random unitary and you still
have to do the same problem uh and your
computational machine can answer like
any your your Oracle can answer any
question about the Horizon unitary right
um and I mean the first one uh is the
thing that I'm claiming that like maybe
will has ideas on the second I think is
essentially the unitary synthesis
problem yeah I see all right all right
maybe we'll talk with Will during the
break so uh um anyone else so you said
you had a half hour of material uh you
know but as we learned from Patrick's
talk everything in quantum gravity is
within a factor of two
so let's take a break
[Applause]